Why do you think,
you know,
there's cars,
there's a kind of a contradictory narrative that runs through that story,
which is that,
you know,
when you,
you're a kid,
you were sort of isolated,
you were bookish,
she were more scientifically oriented,
but at the same time you obviously had a,
what,
what would you call it,
a a feel for ecstatic experience and like was that,
was that a consequence of your participation in the counterculture in the 60s or
was that something that emerged even before that?
It was suddenly an emerge probably between the age of 10 and 12 it probably came
from the fact that I was suffering serious social deprivation.
I'm really,
I had one friend at a time and that's about as much as I had and I was,
I was an indispensable figure when it came time to beat somebody up because I
was the target.
Um,
okay.
How,
So That's interesting too because that also,
I mean it isn't obvious how you get from that position to being interested in
ecstatic experiences per se.
So what,
what's the connection there with your rather like what would you call it?
Isolated childhood experiences,
do you think?
I mean you said it had something partly to do with music,
which makes a perfect,
perfect sense to me because music has almost a,
what would you say?
It's an unerring gateway into that ecstatic experience for for very complex
reasons.
I'd like to talk to you about that a little bit,
but it,
it isn't obvious why someone who was more scientifically oriented say would also
make that leap over to the more mystical end of things and then of course pursue
it through pop culture.
So you laid out,
you know,
you're surprising involvement,
literary magazine,
your transformation of that into what was essentially an visual art publication,
your entry into the world radio and then into rock.
I don't want to lose that thread because that also leads to your PR firm and I
presume we're getting to that,
but what he can,
is there anything you can put your finger on you,
you associated it also with like being physically bullied and being a social
outcast,
but why did that give you that hunger for that experience,
for that ecstatic experience?
Well,
remember back to the days of the 1960 [inaudible],
the 1970s one sleep deprivation was a new discovery and then back in the 1990s
and early two thousands Jaak Panksepp took that a step further.
And in his studies of rat behavior,
he discovered that if he deprived a bunch of child rats,
little rats,
baby rats,
if he deprives them of the ability to play.
Yeah.
And didn't give them access to each other as peers until they,
they become adults.
They suffered play deprivation and they spent just as much time playing with
each other as adults as they would have spent playing with each other.
Have they been allowed to as children?
Okay.
So I want to make a quick lateral move there and we'll get back to that.
You know,
I've been thinking about these,
these strange modern manifestations of identity fantasy or that's what it looks
to me like these people are playing out.
Um,
what do they call them,
other kids and playing with their identities in a really fantasy based way.
And sometimes I wonder if part of that isn't a consequence of play deprivation
in childhood.
Well,
that sounds,
that sounds like it.
The same possibility.
But remember Herman has said that there is somewhere deep dark in the mind.
There's a closet with 10,000 hidden personalities.
One of the things that I discovered,
we're going to get out of chronological order,
but one of the things that I discovered when I first became full time involved
with rock and roll was the story of Alice Cooper.
And the story of Alice Cooper reveals something about the question that you just
raised.
Um,
Alice Cooper was a little bit like me when he was a kid.
His mom used to dress up in a suit every day and he was a gawky then with a huge
nose.
Um,
I was lucky fin with a huge nose.
I can identify.
I never wore suits though.
And he was always a teacher's pet.
And the result was the other kids hated him and he was kicked around and beaten
and,
and excluded the way that I'd been kicked around and beaten,
then excluded.
Then one day a neighbor was at in his kitchen who was into a weegee board and
making contact with spirits through the weegie board.
Um,
so,
uh,
spirit allegedly contacted her and said,
I am the ghost of a witch who was burned of the say in the 16th century and,
or 17th century.
And you pointing to Alice,
I'm pointing to his thing was rinse for an ea at the time,
pointing into Vince,
you are my modern reincarnation and my name is Alice Cooper.
Hmm.
Now when,
when Vince for an ea one onstage and address with Mascara at a high school
talent night for the very first time playing his own music,
chopping up baby dolls with an ax,
which is the more real person,
Vince for NEA,
the shy little kid dressed up in a suit who gave apples to his teacher or Alice
Cooper,
the person on stage who comes to life with an ecstatic identity that makes them
a surfer on the back of those mass passions,
those mass exhilaration that make the forces of history.
Well,
Alice of the two,
they're both real people and they're both inside events for an ea,
but the one that's in there that has a greatest passionate intensity is the
Alice Cooper,
not the Vince for an NEA.
And that's why though he had been picked on and none of the kids in his school
had liked him.
The minute he finished his first performance,
all the football guys who used to beat the crap out of him,
surge down to the foot of the stage and volunteered to be parts of his band.
And when he,
when he was super famous,
some of those guys were still mainstays of his band.
We carry many selves inside of us.
Uh,
my job in PR was to find people who deserve to be iconic and then to explain to
them,
first of all,
I will not,
if you think that I as your publicist,
I'm going to fashion an artificial mask and image and through that make you a
star.
I'm going to get you an appointment with my best competitor immediately you'll
be whether I'm an hours,
um,
if you're going to work with me,
you will have to understand something.
The music you make is about human soul that comes from the very soul of you and
what happens to you when you go out on stage and feel as if to yourself leaves
you and you are a dance like a puppet or like a puppet on a string,
like a marionette on stage.
The force that moves you,
that's one of the gods inside of you that is your soul and what you're
experiencing with that audience is a soul exchange.
If you're willing to put up with the fact that music is not about marketing,
music is not about product.
Music is not about downloads,
music is about these chains are human soul,
then I will work with you.
And quite the statement for a Zionist is to yes,
they talk really is all in that manner.
That's,
you know,
I listen,
tell us Cooper a lot when I was a kid and still now especially that record a
welcome to my nightmare,
which I think is an absolute classic.
You know,
there's a couple of pop songs on it,
which,
which I think,
I mean record companies did that a fair bit on,
on,
on concept albums.
You know,
they'd throw a pop hint on there,
but right as a concept album,
it's brilliant and it's really well arranged and it's really
not horrifying.
Exactly because that's not exactly right,
but it's unbelievably dramatic.
I would say theatrical in in the best way.
And I really think it's a work of genius that welcome to my nightmare.
So,
and I,
I had no idea that,
that that was Alice Cooper's background,
although I did hear that he was the child of a minister.
Is that also correct?
Oh,
no,
no.
His father was in the aerospace industry in Arizona.
Oh,
big aerospace territory.
Right.
But a lot of the kids who were turned on to Alice Cooper and were turned down by
other shark bands like that were the children of,
uh,
ministers,
the children of deeply religious people,
the religious right.
Uh,
because he's bringing out the other side of things.
He,
right,
exactly.
Right.
Well,
he's obviously the precursor of people like Marilyn Manson.
Yes,
exactly.
A Marilyn Manson was to sort of cheap,
even though Marilyn Manson was kind enough to be good.
To me,
Marilyn Manson was a kind of cheap,
uh,
take off.
And Alice Cooper didn't have the staying power that Alice seems to have had.